looking for a simple solution to
transfer data quickly and securely
between object and file storage across
Google cloud with storage transfer
service you can securely move data and
create custom configurations for your
data transfer business needs without
writing a single line of code storage
transfer service is Google's flexible
and secure way to transfer data between
object and file storage across Google
Cloud Amazon Azure on premises and more
all through a single easytouse interface
with storage transfer service you can
transfer pedabytes of data from on-prem
sources or other clouds over online
networks billions of files at tens of
gigabytes per second plus the ability to
configure your data transfer to meet
your business needs manage cost time and
schedule all of this plus security and
reliability built in every step of the
way